attention in addition to the open
problem session tomorrow I try to
combine a little problems from various
thoughts it's possible that I might bug
you once more to check some local high
so I'm going so one of my favorite
metaphors for for math is this kind of
bowl of spaghetti because you never know
where things are going so like this is a
project to sort of begin as trying to
pick apart one some things that I'm
interested in and having them lead to
whole budgets of other things and
actually in in forming these connections
I was also like following the trail of
Rheingold Trevis until tianni and
vidonne so but i extended the the path
of connections a little it's kind of
like joining work products this is work
in progress that's kind of the set of
final author says yet is yet to be
determined
okay so it's not all I'm doing things
with different people I don't know
what's going to come up it so anyway so
as I said like we try to like divide up
our our areas into mathematics into
different sub areas and each like pick a
part of it to concentrate on but what
really happens is when we the divisions
are artificial and you see that
everything is connected
so and this is like one example where
I'm going to show you something that
seems to connect in an abstract
framework a bunch of areas that you that
you know mostly results that you've
already know about but that seem
disconnected for maybe seem disconnected
and the general theme is kind of like
high-level structure versus low-level
randomness so a lot of
a lot of times we like take some
mathematical object and you say well at
a high level at some kind of global
level it has some kind of structure once
you mod out by that global structure
they look at the local level it looks
kind of random so we want to like come
up with we have some kind of object and
we want to come up with some kind of
decomposition into the high-level
structure and then model the low-level
part the details as random of course
they're not random they're a fixed
structure but we want to like say that
these sort of like a random model gives
us as much information as we really need
about it so to look at this as a kind of
abstract setting there's some kind of
probability distribution D that we're
trying to understand okay and that may
be like splotches on the canvas or
outputs of a pseudo-random generator or
or edges in a graph okay and there's
some kind of prior distribution you that
I think of this uniform distribution on
a set but almost everything I'm going to
say is it kind of makes sense for any
kind of prior distribution okay and then
we what do we say you know when we want
to like model things in a way that that
still codes everything we're interested
in if we kind of characterize what we're
interested in so it characterized what
we're interested in as a class of
boolean tests of objects and what we're
interested in for the distribution is
the probability under that distribution
that an object satisfies this test is
okay and all I'm going to assume about
this class of test is it contains the is
closed under complement and it contains
the constant functions for now you can
think of them as boolean tests but
actually like real value tests as long
as they're bounded everything
works pretty much to say okay so Saudi
might be complicated so what we want is
a simple model like understanding D we
want a simple model of D which is going
to be another distribution that we that
is in some sense simple okay and where
this new distribution is a model in the
sense that for any test whether it's one
we've looked at before or not the
expected value of that test on D and the
expected value of the test on D prime
are very close so so what if said we
want a simple model well simple here is
going to mean definable in terms of the
same class of tests in a small number of
the same class of tests that that were
that we're interested in okay so so
maybe more precise because we're going
to have like different constructs over
that class of tests so we might have
like a class of outside function Chi and
then I'm going to use this cumbersome
notation because I'm still getting used
to this to the the slides making
PowerPoint slides gkt is going to be the
class of all functions where you have
some key that has K inputs from this
class key and you have K tests from T
and you compose the the K test with this
this outside function so you don't have
any kind of direct access to the input
except through the kind of filters of
these these simple tests okay and in one
cloud of classes so these may or may not
be boolean functions like if the outside
function is in boolean this might be a
real valued function and one class of
when we say a distribution is of this
form I'm actually going to use a
slightly different instead of having the
distribution directly what I'm going to
have is computable of this form is a
measure
which it's going to be a function from
the support of you 2:01 the interval 0 1
so sorry is every every element a number
it says like sort of what's the weight
under the distribution was you know the
uniform distribution everything would be
equal like weight 1 if we wait some more
than others then then we induce a
distribution proportional to the weight
and you can think of the distribution as
pick X from you and then with
probability U of X keep it otherwise
throw it away and start the sampling
process over and that will pick up an
element with probability proportional to
you now the time of this depends on the
expected value of U of this process to
do one to produce a sample expected time
is going to be one and the the average
value of U so so we want you to be dense
in order for this to really give an
efficient way of producing samples from
this distribution so we define the
density to be the expectation of U of X
where X is drawn from the from the base
distribution ok so some you know this is
pretty abstract whether there are lots
of examples where you can think of is
maybe we're trying to understand some
distribution of points on the plane
maybe even like a continuous
distribution in the test that we're
trying to that we're trying to study our
straight lines that divide the plane
into half spaces okay and then actually
maybe I'll just draw a picture
like maybe we have some distribution it
looks like this these are the you know
hot areas of the distribution and we'll
come up with a simple a simple model of
this distribution would look like like
this
and maybe we would like give each of
these areas probability zero and then
give the uniform distribution how much
have I used point nine you know some
probability on each of these other
regions and then within a region would
be the uniform distribution so that
would be why if we apply I've just been
accidentally squeezing the trigger here
so that would be why what would need to
have a simple districts in pulmonic
distribution and and what we'd want is
two if you draw any other straight lines
that the model in the actual
distribution have about the same
probability fracturing the mass on both
sides of the line so then but it comes
up in in complexity where we want to
look at distributions that look to
computationally bounded adversaries like
other distributions like in
pseudo-random generation you have a
distribution that of the outputs of the
generator you want to say it looks like
the uniform distribution well that's
kind of a simple degenerate case uniform
distribution is just is just the
original distribution you don't have to
use anything but if the distribution
sort of looks like it has more
randomness than it does has pseudo
entropy then then you might want to like
a simple description of a model that
that explains what this is what the
outputs actually look like or comes up
in additive comma Toric's where you have
some kind of subset you have a set of
all integers up to n and and you have
some subset of the integers that you're
trying or distribution on the integers
like random Prime's that you're trying
to understand and you might
like more complicated classic test so uh
or in graph theory
you have the graph that you're trying to
understand a very big graph you're
trying to understand and so you think of
the uniform distribution as picking an
edge in the complete graph at random and
you're comparing that to picking a graph
an edge from your graph at random and
trying to come up with some kind of
model that it gives approximations to
cut properties of the form given a set a
and a set B is does the edge go between
a and B so a lots and lots of other
examples you can you can just make up
your favorite example so like Oh a
distribution on strings and we're
looking at tests that only that RK
hunters that's a good example I like
that one but I don't know that anyone's
actually interested in okay that was
unexpected
what did I do no still on the computer
it's just I disconnect out of
okay okay huh okay so um so I'll try not
to do that again okay so this is sort of
like the general picture of where we're
going kind of clear so there were lots
of from different areas there were there
were lots of different kind of theorems
that said you can do this kind of
decomposition into a high level
structure pardon and a low level random
part so they like state some of these I
have to talk about some concept called
pseudo density so we have this uniform
distribution you and density is like how
big a fraction of you it is so if you
have another distribution D you say it's
going to be like a d fraction of you
means that any test bullying you know
zero one test on you should have at
least well whatever
if you know what probability D sort of a
sample of you is is really subsampling
from D well probability that it should
contribute at least the conditional
probability given that you're in s of T
the gasp of D that given that you're in
D and then if it's boolean outside of D
if you're not from D then it's giving
everything something positive so this is
a lower bound since its characterizes
when when one model is dense within
another this is actual density if you
know density means you can't refute this
in a way that that simple and
efficiently verifiable so you say well
so that means that for any of these
tests that we care about from our family
of tests that T of U is almost as big as
détente what it should be T times T of D
but we allow this like e because if it's
just a infinite testable less than that
then it would even though you know even
if someone gives you the test it would
take you a long time
number of samples before you realize
that this was this this was a violation
of density so put in the slack parameter
e as approximation okay and one way to
be pseudo dense is to be actually dense
within a distribution that looks pseudo
random that looks like the uniform
distribution and this was like the more
traditional way people defined it but I
prefer this way okay so um with that but
now we have the the groundwork for for
saying what the three different styles
of decomposition theorem are did you
have a question or if you're worried
about time I was hoping no I just held
up like three fingers and I was just
that worried me about time I thought you
might be the chair of the session or
something like you said so the one on
top is more general than the one on a
lot of this 1.3 and dot four got three n
book okay so if modulo once you prove
the main structure result you can
retroactively Li show that they're
equivalent but you actually need the
result about that uses them to show that
they're equivalent and they're not in
and it's only kind of like approximately
equivalent quite the same class attack
so okay so this is where I got involved
is first kind is called a hard core set
lemma okay and when it says it's a
you've got some boolean function that's
hard to approximate within by attested
that we care of the simple kind okay
that means that that there's no function
f that simple a small combination of
functions from the class that almost
always computes the value of the
function that we care that we're trying
to they're interested in okay so so if
this is not true then we get what's
called a hard core distribution that's
like a set of subsets of size to D
fraction of to D so real density to D on
which F is almost unpredictable so
outside this hard core set F might be
very simple just given by one of the
functions in the class but inside
there's no even like real correlation
with any function in the class so that
was that was one result I proved a
version of this and then hole and seen
gave a kind of optimal version of this
and there are many different proofs of
this and we'll see that many different
proofs also try in with many different
proofs of other things that were
interested in okay so the second one is
called a transference principle i knew
it at the dense model theorem that's
hence the name of the the talk so this
is by green and tau implicitly but then
talon Ziegler made it explicit but also
Barak shell shell TL and wig Gerson had
an equivalent version in complexity
terms these emerge from additive
combinatorics looking at actually the
the arithmetic progressions within the
primes was the original motivation but
what it says is is kind of abstract says
if if T has this pseudo density property
okay so there isn't this kind of
characterization you know very strong
witnessing that is that it's just a
small fraction of the universe then
there is a model that's
indistinguishable from it according by
these simple tests where the model looks
like it's dense is model is actually
dense and it's indistinguishable so if
you don't if there's no giveaway that
you're not dense then there's a model
that is dense that looks like you and
this was used to like here like the set
they were interested in with the primes
and having a dense model of the primes
gave them the ability uses mr.eddy
theorem on that model
okay and then transfer it back to the
price so what we get from this result is
this kind of dichotomy for any
distribution either there's this kind of
like very small region of the space that
has a much higher probability under that
under that under that distribution then
it would in the uniform distribution
small mu but big in big Indy or there's
this kind of spread out distribution
even though the original distribution is
kind of small there's a spread out big
distribution that looks like the the
distribution according to our simple
class of tests
this make sense so so that's another
style of decomposition theorem and then
a three style came out of a out of graph
theory called regularity lemma z' so the
one I'm talking about so there I'm going
to get back to the there's like the the
you know there's what one makes sense
and what actually happened what would
make sense is that there's a weak notion
of regularity by freezing to none that
was later extended by szemeredi
to give you a much stronger regularity
lemma but at the expense of being going
from an exponential to a stop pile
obtuse but what actually happened was
there was a strong regularity lemma that
was weakened to give a quantitative
improvement much later by freezing
cannot but I'm mainly talking about the
weak version but I'm going to say a few
words about the stronger version in a
couple of minutes if I have time so um
so it says that well if T is actually
going then there is a model that's
simple for for D in it actually this
this step there's already like an
obvious connection because it's dense
model theorem is saying either you get a
witness at the the distribution isn't
dense or you get this kind of model and
the model turns out to be simple okay
and what the regularity lemma says is
well if you're actually dense you can't
have a witness that you're not dense so
you get the model and you know the model
is big but we don't really care about
that we just care that as a simple model
so it's just kind of like a degenerate
regularity then you can see it's like a
degenerate sub case of the dense models
here okay so so what I or where do we
come in so what we're going to show is I
already sort of hinted at why then
model theorem in a totally
straightforward way gives you a week
regularity theorem but we also get such
a direct connection between hard core
set theorems and dense model theorems
and one thing I want to point out is
these when I call them like the dense
model theorem really what this is is a
family of theorems because there are all
sorts of different parameters in this
theorem mainly the K how many tests you
need look what class of and then you
have two class of functions that glue
together the test the test and for
different applications different ways of
gluing them together are important or
sometimes it's just a number of tests
that you need that's important and so
you want to like a trade-off between the
simplicity here and the value K
sometimes you want even like very
particular classes of functions like
that you care about so when I say that
there's this generic connection I mean
with the same class ki the same Class A
and the same K whenever you have ghk
hard core you have a ghk dense model and
a GH k you actually the G disappears but
the h and the K stick around for
regularity moreover all of the reduction
steps in the reduction are totally
algorithmic so if you have an
algorithmic hardcore set serum you get
an algorithmic dense model theorem in an
algorithmic week regularity theorem so I
need to clarify what algorithmic means
in this context and actually was
observed by clive in zen sir video thank
you that what what algorithmic hardcore
set really means is boosting and
boosting is a very successful technique
for machine learning that was introduced
by Shapira
and then sort of perfected by Freudian
Shapira where you put together
weakly correlated hypotheses to a
phenomenon you're observing to in order
to create a very strong explanation for
the phenomenon you're observing and
that's very if you look at what's
happening in the dense model theorem
we're saying if you can always on every
you know dense sorry if you in the hard
core set lemma if on every big subset of
the input there's some way of having a
correlation then you can put them
together and almost always compute the
function so it's actually a one-to-one
correlation with boosting and in fact in
my original paper I used the one of the
proofs of the hard course that lemma
used a boosting algorithm without
labeling it as such ok so and because of
such a successful technique in machine
learning you have all sorts of different
boosting algorithms around and we can
because it's a generic in connection we
can pick our favorite boosting algorithm
and now I have actually five minutes
this is and and use that one so it
actually gives us a wide variety you
know the starting point can be any
boosting algorithm and so we get a wide
variety of dense model theorem
algorithmic dense model theorems in
algorithmic regularity lemma okay so um
okay
so uh
you know and it's very generic so if you
want a dense model if you want a
regularity lemma for sparse graphs you
just say oh I'll make you be sparse
graphs if I if I want a dense model
theorem where a regular dilemma where
where things are proportional to the
grreat vertices I just have an a priori
distribution proportional degrees of
vertices and you get exactly the same
thing so you can just like plug in and
get all sorts of versions of regular
dilemmas
so most of which we already knew but if
you wanted some new ones you could just
go through plug plug it in and pull the
trick crank okay so um and we we can
this only gives a generic result for
weak regularity but I also have been
looking at reverse engineering the
szemeredi regularity lemma and you can
reverse engineer a version of boosting
that's much less efficient but but
basically corresponds to those when you
push it forward corresponds to the
regular regularity lemma okay so um okay
we can also do some some like tricks
building on top of these decomposition
algorithm the difficult position
algorithms so for example if instead of
instead of either finding an area of
where the where is says that the
distribution is is much denser than it
should be
or finding a model what we can do is
like continue finding areas where the
distribution is very dense until there's
none left and then find a model for
what's left so we get the kind of
generic decomposition into the dense
part in a small region in a model for
the for the what's left and that works
for any distribution without assumptions
and we can even use this idea
recursively you have a model for what's
left a small region then you have a
model within that small region and an
even smaller region and so on
and so you can get a a model for a dense
that this is going to hierarchy is going
to have like a logarithmic number of
levels and so instead of having
complexity growing polynomial in one and
E and one and D you have complexity that
grows polynomial one and E and the log
of one and D okay
so these kind of actually go back to a
machine learning we started with you
know the the ideas came from boosting
from machine learning but we can
actually use this to go back to things
that machine learning people have
started being interested in and one big
new idea in machine learning is called
generative adversarial networks you
think of it as two learning algorithms
competing to understand the distribution
so one learning algorithm is trying to
forge things from the distribution the
other is kind of like an art critic
trying to tell the difference between
the forgeries and the real things and
these two algorithms compete with each
other to either find a way of generating
things of fools for the any kind of
critic or find some way of classifying
really pinpointing what is genuine art
what makes genuine art yes which one is
gold well so usually they wanted the
ultimate goal is forgery I think in most
of the applications but here we're kind
of agnostic what we can show is what
course you know this situation actually
corresponds to the dense model lemma and
when you use it in dense model lemma
then what it says is that either there's
a strategy where the where you know one
or the other wins if the critic wins
then that's a very narrow strategy the
narrow narrow very narrow criteria
that's not true of many things from the
uniform distribution but it's true for
most genuine art if the Fourier wins
that gives you a distribution
that's indistinguishable from from the
original so if we look at through the
lens of dense model lemma that sort of
like says that we don't know which side
is going to win but either way it tells
us something very interesting about the
distribution and if we we do a one thing
that the the thing of interest in JN I'm
told is to have models of highest
entropy so if we do it like a little
twist in the in the algorithmic dense
model theorem and use the actual
distribution as a possible distinguisher
test then we get what I call self
reflective GaN algorithm which is
guaranteed to have approximately the
highest possible entropy of any model
okay
and using this going back to complexity
we can go from key ends back to
complexity and complete our below a tour
of this bowl of spaghetti in a loop and
give a characterization for
computational entropy and I think I ran
out of time a couple minutes ago so so
all I'll say is that these kind of
connections allow us to draw on this
kind of vast literature and machine
learning to prove mathematical theorems
and allow us to draw on mathematics to
design new machine learning algorithms
or at least to understand the ones that
are out there so I think this is a kind
of exciting connection that sort of
draws in the whole plate
[Applause]
census official is
so resilient a good thing that sort of
feels like a min/max well okay why
didn't you know we could even extend the
bowl a little bit more a lot of these
boosting techniques are actually you can
think of as strategies for finding
approximate solutions to zero-sum games
so it's notes and going directly through
zero-sum games is an alternative
non-constructive proof of most of these
things so it's not surprising that
people also think of gan is a zero-sum
game
[Applause]
they stop of my